Happy New GEA Year EVERYBODY !
I hope you will have some good... things
In twen-
La blague tourne mal car je ne suis pas bilingue.
Bienvenue dans la première vidéo de 2019 !
La première que je tourne en 2019 pour la chaîne YouTuuuube !
Et rien n'a changé, j'ai le même t-shirt qui pue et la même chaaaise !
Quoi de mieux pour commencer l'année
qu'une vidéo travaillée
sur un ....Ssss...
THREAD !
Depuis que j'fais des vidéos sur les threads vous m'envoyez pas mal de threads et reddits par mails
Et je suis très content je découvre plein de trucs parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il y en a énooormément
Qui parlent de touuuus les sujets !
Alors vous avez très bien compris que ce qui m'intéresse pour les vidéos
c'est les trucs un peu c*ns, un peu drôles.
Mais y'en a plein qui sont pas spécialement drôles et qui sont juste des trucs où t'apprends des choses
sur euh
j'sais pas moi sur la, la, la, la politique
les lois
les derniers "bad buzz" dans tel et tel pays
enfin bref j'vous dis tout et n'importe quoi !
Mais on apprend plein d'trucs en vrai sur Reddit
Nan j'dis ça parce que moi j'ai l'air d'un gros c*n à faire que les threads drôles là sur Reddit !
Mais y'a plein de trucs cools
P't'être qu'on en fera un jour d'ailleurs de certain cool et moins drôles en vidéo pourquoi pas
Mais aujourd'hui on veut...
bien commencer l'année !
On veut...
...sourire et souffler du nez !
Et quoi de mieux pour ça que le thread ?
hmmmmm ? [son difficile à retranscrire à l'écrit]
[son d'apparition]
C'est son nom !
Vraiment il s'appelle "hmmm"
Pourquoi il s'appelle comme ça ? Parce que c'est que des photos qui te font réfléchir
Ou quand tu regardes au premier coup d'oeil, il y a un truc que t'as pas vu
ou alors quand tu regardes il y a un truc, où, tu réalises qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas dans la photo
'fin bref !
C'est très sympatique, très rigolo
On va passer un bon moment convivial
vous et moi
le premier de 2019.
Et j'espère qu'il sera mémorable
[rires]
Excusez moi j'suis très heureux de faire une vidéo
ça fait très longtemps et
ça m'a un peu manqué quoi, j'dois l'admettre !
Aller on y va !
Premier post
hummmmm....
Non, mais le fameux, on l'a vu dans le truc TikTok
Mec, cette carte elle est surpuissante gros, elle change le sens des choses.
Tu peux tout renvoyer avec ça : les insultes, un licenciement
Tout !
Je pense, si je puis me permettre peut-être que je m'enflamme Mr.Macron,
Qu'il faudrait interdire cette carte. Son pouvoir est sous-côté.
On passe à la suivante.
hmmmmm ? [son difficile à retranscrire à l'écrit]
[rires]
Il transporte une soucoupe, oui, il a des lunettes de yeux d'aliens
Mmmmh OUI MMMH
Il s'agit bien évidemment d'un montage heu de toutes pièces.
Ayant pour but de faire rire et de divertir une communauté Reddit, bien évidemment.
Nous ça ne nous a pas trop atteint, on va pas se mentir.
Mmmmh [Rires]
J'ai compris pendant mon "Mmmh"
Twix, vous n'avez pas honte?
Les sachets font la même taille.
Pourquoi le blanc est plus petit que le noir ?
Quel message avez vous essayer de faire passer à travers votre produit ? Quel message Twix ? C'est Scandaleux !
Et je dis pas ça parce que je suis le blanc..
Mmmmh [Rires]
Mec bête d'idée
C'est une bête d'idée, ça devrais être obligatoire, ouais, il devrait y avoir une loi sur ça.
On doit tous avoir un petit triangle et un gilet jaune là dans le coffre là lorsque l'on tombe en panne ben on devrais avoir ça à l'avant de nos caisses mec
Ça t'avertit si t'es trop proche de la voiture, ça amortit le choc si tu lui est rentré dedans.
C'est tout bénef gros !
Et quand vous marcherez dans la rue y'aura ce bruit là tout le temps
[Bruit de coqs en plastique qui couinent]
hmmmmm.
*inspire* mec j'ai même pas vu
je n'ai même pas vue *en riant*
Il a volé la salière à mamie le c*n !
Mec, en vrai l'idée est géniale, parce que, psychologiquement ton adversaire est déstabilisé.
C'est sûr, gros.
Et si en plus tu joues en mangeant, ça a son utilité.
C'est pas un "hmmm" du tout.
Ca devrai aller dans le reddit "OUI"!
*bruit de la reflexion*
Bah mec
hmm ?
HMMMMMM !!!!
Hmmmm ! *approbateur*
*bruit de crachat*
oh ! *inspire*
J’espère que mes enceintes avaient un parapluie.
Mona Lisa prend le bus ligne 57 ?!
Elle est comme nous !
On la surcote là, les touriste ils viennent de partout dans le monde pour la voir, là, peint.
Mais nous les français. on la voit dans le bus mon pote !
On la voit dans le bus pour aller à Chatelet !
Mais c'est incroyable !
Elle est sortie du tableau ? On a vérifié au Louvre si elle était encore dans le tableau ?
*bruit d'alarme strident et de gens qui crient*
*petite musique*
hmmm
hmm.. *rit*
Simple, sympa, on passe un moment tranquille
Absolument absurde mais terriblement efficace, je doit l'admettre
*même petite musique*
hmm
*rit*
Quel gamin !
Avouez on s'est tous dit ça
"quel gamin, mais qu'est ce qu'il a raison"
Qu'est ce que c'est drôle p*tain !
Pour nous c'est drôle, mais quand lui dans des années, il repensera à ces moments là en cours.
où au lieu de travailler, il a fait le con, il a fait le zigoto
à dessiner ses profs sur Paint
et qu'à cause de ça, il a raté son diplôme
et qu'il n'a pas eu le travail de ses rêves et qu'il n'est pas content de son quotidien 5 ans après
quand il se rendra compte de tous ça, il va regretter d'avoir dessiné un moustachu à binocles ! OK !?
Waaa, je sais pas ce que j'ai la, c'est la rentrée ça me réussi pas du tout.
hmm
*rit*
C'est génial ce moment, où tu crois qu'il n'y a rien, et d'un coup tu comprends qu'il y a tout en fait !
*gémie*
*gémie
HMMMMM !
Bien évidemment, le poteau était probablement cassé,
cette déduction ne peut pas nous échapper quand même, on va pas se mentir.
MAIS attention si vous passer devant un restaurant thaïlandais à ne pas vous asseoir
en plus c'est en France *rit*
si tu regarde cette vidéo, bisou à toi. On espère bien évidement que y'avais pas le dessus du poteau
OOH !
Oh nooon. Moi j'ai jamais réussi à voler le nez !
Ça marche avec les statues en fait !
C'est un truc de statue !
Très amusant très efficace et je dit pas ça parce que ma grand mère s'amusait à faire cette blague tout le temps quand j’étais petit...
*image de levier de vitesse en braille (pour les aveugles) pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris (dont moi je dois l'admettre)*
Il est évident que c'est un.... fake
Mais je doit l'admettre... c'est sympa !
Là j'avoue tu as envie de lâcher ton meilleur "hmm".
hmmm
*rire*
Ca me fatigue gros... cette vidéo elle fatigue non ?
C'est pas de l'humour qui vous fatigue ça ?
Ca me détruit !
J’étais bien, j’étais en forme maintenant je suis fatigué après cette image la.
hmm *rit*
Ah ça devient glaaauque !
Plus on passe plus c'est glauque mec c'est incroyable.
Mais nooon mais quelle idée de meeerde
Mais quelle idée de merde ! Mais je n'ai pas d'autre mots.
*rit*
Mec... quand j'ai regardé Breaking Bad, il y'a longtemps, j'ai bloqué sur ça.
Sur la ressemblance entre ce mec et ce mec.
Il y'en a aucune pourtant, aucune !
Attendez
Mais c'est...
Mais c'est outrant !
Mais il y'a un nombre de chose outrant dans cette vidéo.
Mais on commence très mal 2019
Ils sont si innocents
Ils ne comprennent pas du tous qu'en voyant cette photo... on va les prendre pour des gros salauds.
C'est horrible gros !
haaa *de dégoût*
Ça me fait mal au doigts rien que d'y penser vieux !
Des bagues pour les doigts gros, qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Il s'est passé un truc là hein ?
Il s'est passé un truc.
Pour avoir affiché des tests pour daltonien dans le fond de la boutique.
Hein ?
*musique mignonne*
*musique angoissante*
*inspiration*
Mais mec..
Mais faites attention quand vous êtes dans des costumes comme ça vous pouvez traumatiser une famille entière.
Surtout qu'ils avaient pas du tout l'air heureux d’être dans tes bras à ce moment là.
Je comprends pourquoi !
Qu'est ce qu'il ce passe ?
hmmm ?
*musique épique et bruit de détecteur*
Mec j'l'ai pas !
Je l'ai pas et ça me rend fou !
Je ne l'ai pas, ce sentiment de faiblesse et d'être à coté de la plaque !
Haaa ok..
Haaa ! Je le vois pas parce que je suis daltonien y'a un mec qui le dit en commentaire !
Oooh mec j'ai eu peur !
J'ai cru que je devenais un gros con *rip si toi non plus t'as rien vu*
En fait la vanne
Mais vous le voyez vous, vous devez me prendre pour un con
C'est qu'ils ont le même - la même couleur des lèvres les deux la et ça veut dire qu'ils se sont embrassés.
Mais elle pose avec lui en mode c'est lui son petit ami.
Mais on sait qu'elle a embrassé lui puisqu'ils ont la même couleur de lèvres.
Ah bah je vais faire une émission où j'explique les blagues pour les gogoles comme moi allez on y va haha
Mec, j'ai mis mille ans a comprendre ça, ça m'a rendu fou !
P*TAIN!
*rires*
Ça fait peur mec !
Elle n'est pas supposée du tout.
Regarder la caméra dans le reflet !
Éloigne toi enfant maudit !
Oh ce thread, il me remue ! On passe par toutes les émotions.
Écoutez, si il passe un meilleur moment comme ça, euh... laissez le hein.
On rigole mais dans 15 ans on sera tous comme des cons comme ça vous allez voir. Rigolons tant qu'on peut.
WOOOH
hep hep hep hep hep
On va voir si vous avez révisé là avant 2019, si vous êtes prêts a regarder les vidéos de 2019
Comment ça s'appelle ça ? Hein !?
-réponse A: la paraydolie
-réponse B : la paréidolie
-réponse C : le doliprane
Aloooors?
Bravo
Ça c'est mes élèves ça ! Ça c'est mes élèves vous en faites pas on va faire un bon deuxième trimestre ensemble.
hmmm
Mais... comment peuvent-ils planter le drapeau américain sur la lune si qu'on voit la lune de là ou ils sont ?
hmmmmmmmm
Si sexiste. J'imagine à la place de la fille et que cette scène soit vraie, l'enfer, le cauchemard.
haaaaa
Arrêtez là il y'a même plus de 'hmmmm"
Là y'a juste des cris et de l'étonnement  la, et du scandale ! Arrêtez ! Ne me fait pas une pizza avec ton ventre.
*musique du titanic*
*musique du titanic mal jouée et avec une flûte*
Et mec, mais ça me fait trop rire le truc avec les dessins c'est hyper drôle cette vanne
De pas faire du tout ce qui est prévu
C'est super drôle mec
woh-p ?
wopopopo
Il s'est passé quoi là ?
hmmm
hmmmmm-non non non nonononon
ah *de dégoût*
AH *de dégoût*
HAA
Regardez je vais dire un mot, je vais dire un mot et vous allez fermer la vidéo.
CONJONCTIVITE !
HAAAAA
Et bien nous voila arrivés au bout de ce thread.
J’espère que vous avez beaucoup "hmmm-er"
C'est un verbe que nous venons d'inventer ensemble
Ça faisait longtemps, là, que j'avais pas trainé sur Reddit, et mec euh...
C'est un vrai réseau social !
Je le sais puisque je commence à être accro !
C'est pas bien du tout !
N’hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude si les thread vous plaisent
Pour cette année il y'aura probablement quelques nouvelles sortes de vidéos qui apparaîtront.
Dans le même esprit que ce que je fait là, avec les thread etc...
Alors certains peuvent trouver ça facile mais franchement je kiffe faire ça.
Même si c'est simple je m'en fous
Je passe un bon moment, ça me fait marrer.
Les codes d'humour de ces images là ont en fait, c'est vraiment la culture web.
Et je trouve ça cool de faire des vidéos là-dessus.
Et j'aimerais bien aussi parler un petit peu des buzz de France et tout qu'y a bref...
J'ai pas mal d'idées comme ça un peu en mode "talk show" à faire euh... cette année je trouve ça cool ça changera un peu de ce qu'on a fait l'année dernière
En tous cas je vous fait plein de gros bisous !
D'ailleurs je vais aussi changer ce décor dans 2-3 vidéos il aura complètement changé
Donc ce sera aussi l'occasion de faire des nouveau formats de vidéos.
Je vais tenter des truc je vais me faire plaisir comme l'année dernière, voila, sortir de sa zone de confort, se faire kiffer, s'amuser !
C'est le plus important pour moi cette année je vous l'avait déjà dit !
Merci d'avoir regardé ça !
N'oubliez pas si vous voyez une photo où vous ne comprenez pas tout n’hésitez pas à lâcher votre meilleur "hmmm" !
Ça me fera plaisir !
Je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo !
N’hésitez pas à m’envoyer par mail des threads cools de Reddit si il y'a des truc,
Même pas forcement c*n, hein, mais des trucs intelligents, des truc cools qui apprennent des choses n’hésitez pas a m'envoyer
J'en ai pas mal que j'ai repérés là dont je vais vous parler.
Mais bon, si jamais je peux passer a coté de certains.
Je vous dit à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo et j'ai hâte que le décor change, et j'ai hâte de vous montrer les prochains décors.
Il va être très sympa je ferai une vidéo set-up pour l'occasion
*TAP TAP*
BISOUs TOUS LE MONDE !